from bizarre tonal mashups to
unfortunate real world connections it's
terrifying just how many ways horror
movies can flop at the box office
warning this video contains Fast
Flashing images viewer discretion is
advised especially for those with
photosensitive epilepsy
just before hostile part 2 arrived in
theaters in June 2007 a work print copy
of the feature leaked onto the internet
when the movie proceeded to take in just
33.6 million dollars worldwide a
whopping 60 drop from the original
hostel writer director Eli Roth blamed
the piracy but while that certainly
didn't help it wasn't the only problem
for one thing while the first hostel was
a hit it wasn't exactly the sort of
beloved horror movie that makes fans
demand a sequel it was an early January
release that got a box office Boost from
being the only gruesome title in a
Marketplace otherwise dominated by award
season fair and family movies meanwhile
part 2 dropped in the middle of the
summer so it faced much more serious
competition on top of all of that the
marketing failed to offer any new
elements to Intrigue moviegoers as the
trailers and posters just tease more
drizzly Carnage simply put you need more
than that to excel in the Blockbuster
days of summer nobody involved in 1999's
The Haunting could have imagined the
other horror movie that would end up
upstaging it how could anything
overshadow an 80 million dollar horror
movie starring Liam Neeson Fresh Off
Star Wars Episode 1 The Phantom Menace
but the haunting opened in close
proximity to The Blair Witch Project
which vastly surpassed the box office
intake of the costly remake grossing
just
180.1 million dollars worldwide The
Haunting was expected to earn much more
than that with all of its big name
actors and a familiar brand name
unforeseen bad timing wasn't the only
issue here the movie also stood out like
a sore thumb in the late 90s horror
landscape which was enjoying fresh takes
on the genre and the likes of scream in
hindsight The Haunting actually
anticipated the mid-2000s obsession with
horror remakes like 2003's the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre and 2004's Dawn of the
Dead But at the time it was just a
ho-hum box office disappointment that
didn't make the impact it was supposed
to
I don't know
on the surface 2019's doctor sleeps
seemed to have everything going for it
it was a sequel to the iconic horror
film The Shining it had a big name actor
in the form of Ewan McGregor in the lead
role and it was opening over the
Veterans Day holiday weekend surely a
Marketplace that seems to always respond
to nostalgia-driven horror sequels would
turn out in droves for Dr sleep instead
it became a surprise box office
non-starter when it grossed just 71.8
million dollars worldwide on a 45
million dollar budget part of the
problem here was that without the
shining in the title Dr sleep had an
uphill battle convincing people that it
was actually a sequel to that classic
the marketing ended up getting caught
between a rock and a hard place too many
ads relied solely on callbacks to the
original which made it look derivative
while it was also never fully apparent
to viewers that this continued the story
of The Shining it also didn't help that
this was an artsier kind of horror movie
with a slower pace and scares derived
from an eerie atmosphere rather than
just jumps scares this all but ensured
that Dr sleep was well received enough
critically while audiences on the fence
stayed away
with 2012's Paranormal Activity 4 the
found footage franchise saw its box
office clout abruptly shrink
dramatically a series that had cleared
100 million dollars domestically with
ease one year prior with Paranormal
Activity three now barely collected 50
million dollars in North America the
ultra cheap price tags on these movies
ensured that this was still a profitable
Venture but it was also clear that the
sheen was wearing off so it's no
surprise that the temporarily final
installment 2015's the ghost Dimension
delivered even deeper box office lows
the ghost Dimension grossed just 18.3
million dollars in North America not
only the lowest domestic Hall of any
entry in the series but also smaller
than the opening weekend sums of all
prior installments that abnormally
minuscule take can be attributed to
Paramount Pictures engaging in a quicker
than usual home video release strategy
that alienated enough theater chains to
ensure that the ghost Dimension would
play on a much smaller number of screens
than usual overseas roses would lift the
movie to a 70 7.9 million dollar
worldwide total enough to ensure that
Paramount didn't lose money but this
Global gross was a far cry from what the
earlier entries had brought in just a
few years earlier and made Paranormal
Activity 4 look like a barn burner by
comparison you know why I screamed why
it's because I saw this through the
camera The Blair Witch Project was such
a gargantuan box office success in 1999
that it seemed like a foregone
conclusion that it would spawn several
lucrative sequels alas attempts to turn
it into a franchise have repeatedly hit
a brick wall this was even true for
2016's Blair Witch which attempted to
mine potential Nostalgia for the
original movie into a relaunched
franchise unfortunately it didn't quite
work out that way box office
prognosticators predicted that Blair
Witch would make more than 20 million
dollars in its domestic opening weekend
but instead that total ended up being
the entirety of its North American run a
big problem was the state of the found
footage genre Circa 2016. it was a novel
gimmick and 1999 when The Blair Witch
Project was Unleashed on the masses but
audiences were outright rejecting the
excess of mid-2010s found footage horror
titles this sub-genre had become a
cliche rather than an exciting
subversion and not even the return of
the Blair Witch brand name could
overcome that plus the marketing didn't
promise anything substantially new
compared to the original further
cementing its cruel box office fate
it would be understandable for most
moviegoers who saw the trailer for
Brahms The Boy 2 to respond with
confusion and by asking was there a
First the boy indeed there was an
original the boy though it was released
back in January 2016 to little Fanfare
while not necessarily a flop it also
wasn't exactly the kind of movie that
generated enough enthusiasm to get
people hankering for another installment
but rare is the mildly profitable horror
movie that doesn't inspire a sequel so
Brahms The Boy 2 arrived in theaters in
February 2020. debuting in this time
frame meant that Brahms had only a few
weeks to make money before the covid-19
pandemic would totally upend the entire
theatrical business but even before that
crisis took hold Brahms was a box office
non-starter that grossed only 18.9
million dollars globally on a 10 million
dollar budget Not only was the original
the boy not beloved by any stretch of
the imagination it was also four years
old by the time a sequel arrived an
eternity when it comes to horror any
Revenue to be soaked up through brand
name recognition was long gone by this
point resulting in an inexplicable
sequel nobody asked for if you'd like to
go all you need to do is to say I'd like
to go now
Case 39 started filming back in 2006 and
under normal conditions it would have
been ready to go for either a 2007 or
2008 release however this horror film
wouldn't find its way to movie theaters
until October 2010 despite being
headlined by actors like Renee Zellweger
and Bradley Cooper so what happened just
a month before case 39's debut
Entertainment Weekly published an
extensive rundown of its troubled
history with Paramount Pictures
scheduling two separate dates in 2008
and 2009 before leaving it undated for
over a year director Christian alvart
attributed this to the film being a
smaller scale fair that the studio
didn't see as a priority whatever the
reason for the constant delays all the
rescheduling and then the abrupt release
didn't signal much in the way of
confidence with only a minimal
promotional push Case 39 grossed just
28.7 million dollars globally on a 21
million dollar budget part of the
problem wasn't just the marketing but
also the crowded Marketplace October
2010 was full of horror movies including
Saw 3D and Paranormal Activity 2 with
Case 39 opening directly against the
vampire flick let me in opening a film
with so little buzz against so many
other scary films just cemented the
deadly fate of case 39. every horror
franchise hits its Financial low Point
eventually for The Nightmare on Elm
Street Series this all-time low Point
came with 1994's Wes Craven's New
Nightmare which topped out at just 18
million dollars director Wes Craven
attempted something fresh with new
nightmare with a new version of Freddy
Krueger and a meta-narrative involving
the filming of A New Nightmare on Elm
Street movie within the movie but that
high-minded premise may have been a bit
too impenetrable to mainstream audiences
other factors may have included a
minimal marketing budget and competition
from the likes of Pulp Fiction it also
can't be ignored that in 1994 the shine
had worn off Freddy Krueger quite a bit
the previous nightmare movies had
garnered negative reviews and
transformed the dream killer from an
intimidating foe into a predictable
punch line even with New Nightmare
promising something different audiences
just weren't psyched for anything more
considering everything against it it's
honestly a wonder that it managed to
make even the meager amount that it did
however it happened story dies the evil
is set free
nowadays 1987's near dark is considered
occult classic that's garnered Acclaim
from critics for its subversion of
typical gender Norms in westerns as well
as widespread praise for a delightful
performance from Bill Paxton it's proved
to be enduringly popular enough to make
it seem odd that the film wasn't just a
box office stud in its original
theatrical release but barely even got
released into theaters directed by
Catherine Bigelow near dark roast 3.3
million dollars domestically with no
recorded international box office
figures to speak of that was nowhere
near enough to cover its five million
budget but the problems weren't on the
movie itself Instead The Faults lie with
the distributor which released near dark
in only 262 theaters for comparison's
sake the original Hellraiser that same
year managed to play in 1104 locations
with no real opportunities for
moviegoers to actually go out and watch
near dark on the big screen how could it
ever suck up any profitability
who doesn't love Anthony Hopkins iconic
portrayal of Hannibal Lecter while other
actors like Brian Cox and mass Mickelson
have also delivered beloved portrayals
of this cannibal doctor Hopkins
oscar-winning performance is undoubtedly
the one most associated with the
character this proved to be an
insurmountable hurdle for 2007's
Hannibal Rising the first feature film
adaptation of the character in over two
decades that attempted to present a
Hannibal Lecter movie without Hopkins
this prequel explored a younger version
of vector as played by french actor
Gaspar juliel it's easy to see why
producers saw dollar signs that the
prospect of making a new movie with
Lecter that didn't require handing over
a hefty paycheck to Hopkins but the
doctor just wasn't as appealing to mass
audiences without him on board plus
there really wasn't any demand from even
die hard fans to explore this backstory
with Hannibal Rising coming on the heels
of two other Lecter movies in the six
preceding years moviegoers had already
had their fill and a prequel without
Hopkins certainly wasn't going to
inspire them to return and so Hannibal
Rising grossed just 80.5 million dollars
globally a far cry from The Silence of
the Lamb's
275.7 million dollars yeah
that was good
genre mashups are frequently a tough
sell to audiences even horror comedies
have often struggled financially let
alone more complex mixtures like sci-fi
westerns so it shouldn't be considered a
shock that the 1999 Western horror
cannibal flick ravenous didn't exactly
set the box office on fire ultimately
this unusual horror title grossed just 2
million dollars in its entire theatrical
run adding to all the inherent hurdles
were the facts that ravenous was only
released in 1040 locations and it didn't
have any big names in its cast it was
also an odd fit for a wide theatrical
release and likely would have fared
better years later with more fluid
release models that deliver Oddball
titles to Niche audiences with greater
ease but The Saga of ravenous didn't end
with its box office run like many horror
movies that initially stumbled at the
box office it's managed to ride a second
wave of Life on home video
there were a lot of problems facing
2018's Slenderman Chief among them was
the gruesome fact that the release was
coming on the heels of a tragedy in
Wisconsin where two teenage girls
attempted to kill a friend because of
the supposed influence of the Slenderman
there was also the fact that when the
movie came out it was arriving way too
late to fully capitalize on the initial
popularity of its titular monster then
there was the reported 28 million dollar
price tag on top of everything else the
producers of Slenderman clashed with
Sony over the film's marketing leading
the studio to consider selling the film
to a streaming service considering all
this it's no surprise then that
Slenderman wiped out at the box office
with just 51.9 million dollars globally
that put it behind the worldwide verses
of notably cheaper 2018 horror titles
like hereditary and Truth or Dare some
movies managed to outrun their
problematic pasts but Slenderman ended
up consumed by them hey come here
foreign
Carpenter directed classic the thing
wasn't exactly beloved upon its initial
release but it's enjoyed a
reconsideration in the ensuing years
with fans coming to embrace it as one of
the best horror movies ever made at the
time of its release though it was panned
by contemporary critics who were quick
to bash the films over the top Gore and
measured pacing as it was going up
against other sci-fi Giants such as
Blade Runner and E.T it's not too
shocking that a slow burn like the thing
got outmatched but it's a little more
surprising that the 2011 prequel of the
same name did even worse the latter
version featured an impressive
International cast of actors including
Mary Elizabeth Winstead Joel Edgerton
and edwale akonoye akbaje as researchers
at a Norwegian Antarctic Outpost who
discover a shape-shifting alien despite
high expectations the thing proved to be
a massive box office Bomb by only making
31 million dollars on a 38 million
dollar budget as Box Office Mojo
reported at the time of its opening
weekend there was a Prof invasive
cynicism about the need for a remake
within the horror Community though and
with an identical story location and
title there didn't appear to be much of
a reason to head to theaters it also
didn't help that the production team
infamously ditched all their practical
effects in favor of subpar CGI which was
a crucial reason why fans loved the 1982
version so much
a rather unique entry on this list is
Jennifer's Body the 2009 horror slasher
comedy directed by Karen kusama and
written by Diablo Cody about a high
school girl who's possessed by a demon
it stars Megan Fox and Amanda seifred
with a Supporting Cast that includes
Adam Brody among others it's been
critically reappraised in recent years
as a satirical and self-aware piece of
feminist filmmaking that's also gained a
place in the pantheon of queer and
bisexual Cinema according to Cody the
marketing team behind Jennifer's Body
didn't do the movie any favors as she
explained to Vox in 2018 the movie was
marketed all wrong I'm not usually an
argumentative person in fact I'm really
passive but that was like the one time
I've gotten in a fight because I was so
Furious while the film did actually get
a notable female leaning audience the
marketing issues were enough to cause
Jennifer's Body to be a box office
disappointment it made only 6.8 million
dollars during its opening weekend and
only 31.5 million dollars worldwide
during its whole run I am a god
okay
directed by Guillermo del Toro the 2015
Gothic horror romance Crimson Peak
seemingly had everything going for it it
boasted an award-winning director an
intriguing setting and a stacked cast of
Hollywood Talent including Tom
Hiddleston and Jessica chasteen the plot
told the mysterious tale of a woman
solving otherworldly clues in a spooky
Mansion seemingly haunted by the ghosts
of previous inhabitants despite all this
Crimson Peak was a disappointment at the
box office audiences were mostly
uninterested as it racked up only 31
million dollars total in North America
while it did make a profit in total with
a 74 million dollar worldwide Hall it
Still Remains seen as a major
disappointment for a movie with such
considerable star power according to
deadlines analysis the film
underperformed primarily due to it being
up against bigger and possibly better
movies with the site reporting Crimson
Peak suffered from a very competitive
PG-13 adult market for such films as the
Martian and Bridge of spies were over
forming 2006's Slither was one of
director James Gunn's first major big
screen projects after his time in the
ultra low budget world of troma movies
Gunn is now best known for his
stewardship of the Guardians of the
Galaxy franchise and his strong hand in
overseeing DC projects like The Suicide
Squad and Peacemaker but the struggles
of Slither show that before all that he
had to emerge from much humbler
Beginnings one thing fans consistently
love about Gunn is his sense of humor
which carries over into nearly all of
his films but in the case of Slytherin
that may have been more of a liability
than an asset the film confused
audiences at the time by mixing horror
with black comedy and sci-fi to concoct
a strange story that many viewers
struggled to wrap their heads around
even at the time Gunn revealed that it
was a bit too overwhelming for some
audiences as he admitted to The
Hollywood Reporter in 2006 I think that
because it was comedy horror instead of
pure horror is where the problem lay
it's the first comedy horror in a long
time and maybe the the marketplace just
isn't ready for comedy horror yet it's
difficult to think of other explanations